we have updated vaccine polling data
from monmouth university we now know
that roughly one in five americans
still do not want the covet vaccine and
those numbers are
heavily and significantly led by
republicans 43
of whom still do not want the coveted
vaccine and do not plan to get it
if they can avoid it i guess that if
they can avoid it suggest
something about if it became a
requirement for a job or to do something
they want to do
maybe they would get it overall the good
news is that the number who don't want
the vaccine
is down but it's not really down
dramatically earlier in the pandemic we
saw significant reductions in vaccine
hesitancy it's really leveling out now
the numbers are stunningly partisan
if you look at numbers by party 43
percent of republicans do not want the
vaccine
22 percent of independents do not want
the vaccine
and just 5 percent of democrats do not
want the vaccine
uh if it were all democrats we would get
to herd immunity
if it were all independents we might
it would be 78 due and if it were up to
only republicans if everybody believed
what republicans believe
we would not get to herd immunity
although maybe eventually we would
because so many of them would get sick
that they develop natural immunity
that's a different story though
many would die in that process now also
interesting is that the racial gap seems
to almost have completely gone away at
least according to this poll
22 percent of whites and 20 percent of
people of color
don't want the vaccine that is now
essentially statistically equal there
was a point in time at which there was
more of a gap
led by vaccine hesitancy among the black
american
community so the big takeaway is
if 80 percent of the country plans to
get vaccinated
we can actually reach something
approximate approximating herd immunity
which medical science believes again it
depends on
how contagious is whatever variant
becomes dominant and
how uh sort of homogeneous versus
heterogeneous
is vaccination somewhere between 70
and 85 vaccination would be required to
achieve
heard however one thing we have to
remember
is that vaccine opposition is not
homogenous it varies greatly in
different parts of the country
the mississippi massachusetts gap
right now is a really good example 92
percent of those in massachusetts want
the vaccine
mississippi is already at the point
where tons of vaccination appointments
are going unfilled
demand is lagging so you could end up
with a situation where some states are
sort of
extra vaccinated well beyond what's
required for herd immunity
and other states never reach it and you
have constant small clusters and
outbreaks which will just
extend the pandemic the sad part is
that because some people don't develop
immunity even when you get vaccinated
remember it's a 95
effective vaccine some others can't get
the vaccine because of specific medical
conditions
you will have a situation where those
who could get it but just choose not to
will give the virus to some of the folks
who either got the vaccine but didn't
develop immunity
couldn't get the vaccine because of
medical condition and some of them will
die
that's that's the decision of anybody
who could get it and chooses not to
is that you are increasing the odds that
somebody dies as a result of your
actions
i'm glad i'm not participating in that
uh other information
from the poll approval for joe biden so
far is really looking pretty good 54
approval for biden remember that donald
trump never got to 50
approval even once during his presidency
62 approval for joe biden's handling of
the virus that's up from 57 percent in
march there was the idea that it was up
in march
but it's going to go down as biden uh
becomes the new normal
uh covet approval for biden continuing
to go up
for comparison biden at 62 trump was at
34
approval on kovid when he left office
and 63 percent approval for biden's
covet stimulus bill which was passed
last month so the numbers are looking
very solid for joe biden i think getting
infrastructure done would boost them a
little bit
but infrastructure is less visible to
the average person and it also
takes longer than just something gets
passed and then you get 1400 bucks
so the impact on approval may be maybe
lower one last thought
the pause going on right now on the
johnson and johnson vaccine which we
talked about earlier this week
it is giving a boost to the anti-vaxx
people
and it will be something that we will
have to wait and see the effect of
we see it impacting people anecdotally
saying well now i'm
definitely never getting any vaccine
uh seeing that on social media that
wasn't yet part of this polling
information so if we now see a reversal
and vaccine hesitancy goes up
it would be important to look at whether
the pause on the jnj vaccine
is a factor in that one of our sponsors
today is
nebia the creator of the world's most
innovative
shower head it uses only about half
the water that other shower heads do
saving you money helping the environment
but it's actually a lot more powerful
than other shower heads on the market it
has twice the coverage of other shower
heads
the water sprays with a ton of pressure
i've been using it in my bathroom at
home i love it
only took a few minutes to set up really
easy and it's been a totally different
experience
than any other shower head i've used i
can get in and out of the shower way
quicker now
because of how powerful it is it only
takes a few seconds to get
completely rinsed off so i was actually
amazed that it's only using about
half as much water nebia also offers a
number of shower accessories like
shelves and curtains which match
perfectly with the design of the shower
head the shower head starts at just 199
but the first hundred people who go to
nebia.com
pacman and use code pacman will get
15 off all nebia products the link is
underneath this video